Speaker 1: All right, we're going to go through
two confrontations that took place over the
last few days, they are very different in
nature.
I think there are some important things to
be said about both.
Rand Paul was confronted by a Kentucky resident
during a town hall that he did.
We're going to look at that a little bit later.
But first, I want to talk about what happened
to Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson when
he was at a fishing store, a fish supply tackle
bait type store.
You can tell I don't fish in the state of
Montana where he was confronted.
And what I want to we're going to look at
the video.
We're going to look at the reporting.
But what I really want to focus in on here
are two things.
One, the reactions about the nature of what
took place here from a speech standpoint,
that's number one.
And then number two, the utter disgusting,
dripping hypocrisy that comes with this tactic,
which I've also I mean, you guys might remember,
I recently was also confronted by someone
who disagreed with my political views in public.
So let's get right into it.
Huffington Post report man confronts Tucker
Carlson at Montana Store.
You are the worst human being when a local
fly fishing guide spotted noted vaccine skeptic
Tucker Carlson at a sporting goods store in
Livingston, Montana, he did not waste time.
Dan Bailey can be heard telling the Fox News
host in a video, you were the worst human
being known to mankind, he captioned the video.
It's not every day you get to tell someone
they are the worst person in the world and
really mean it.
What an asshole.
There's one other interesting aspect to this
which which I will get back to.
OK, so here is the video.
If you're watching, it's subtitled.
It's only about twenty five seconds long,
but I don't care
Speaker 2: who you are.
You have be my own man.
Unidentified: I want you to me to this experience
leads to everything else in this world.
I don't have to ask you
Speaker 2: what you've done to everybody else.
Speaker 1: Was settled down.
Son is very, very condescending.
And Tucker is an expert, clearly in being
condescending, probably picked up those techniques
that his various country clubs from reports
about how he treats the staff at country clubs
a little bit more here.
Speaker 2: Oh, I want to.
Speaker 1: All right.
So Tucker then walking away and looking apparently
at some flies or bait or something like that.
Now, here's one before we get into this here.
Here's the most incredible part of this entire
story.
The guy who confronts Tucker Carlson is named
Dan Bailey.
The confrontation happened at Dan Bailey's
fly shop, but the Dan Bailey, who did the
confrontation, has nothing to do with Dan
Bailey's fly shop.
It's a coincidence that a guy named Dan Bailey
in Livingston, Montana, is in Dan Bailey's
shop and is not actually the Dan Bailey from
the shop.
Like, is this a common name or something?
And it's an incredible detail that just adds
to the entire insanity of it.
But OK, so what are the reactions?
I mean, this was a speech, right, guys?
There was no physical violence.
If anything, it was actually Tucker Carlson,
who at different points in time is sort of
getting very, very close to Dan Bailey and
getting up really close to him.
If you could argue if anybody was physically
intimidatory here, it was really more tucker
than anybody else.
So clearly, right wingers are in favor of
the speech, right?
Well, not exactly.
Check out what Dinesh D'Souza said, big free
speech advocate, quote, This is a shocking
video.
This man should be arrested for what he did
to Tucker Carlson in front of his daughter.
First of all, the moralizing about in front
of his daughter, I don't even know that I
get that.
But certainly it has no criminal relevance.
But what would you arrest Dan Bailey for that
he expressed a view that is different than
that of Dinesh D'Souza or different than that
of Tucker Carlson or different than that of
Tucker Carlson's daughter.
Maybe.
I mean, who knows what Tucker Carlson's daughter's
political views are?
You are all about free speech and not regulating
and above all this different stuff.
And you want someone arrested for something
they said when it was Tucker who got real
close to the guy and actually started poking
him on the chest.
What crime, sir?
Speaker 2: Sir, sir.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So this happened to me not that long ago.
OK, I described the incident a little while
ago.
I was sitting outside at a terrace at a restaurant.
And as I was walking away, I heard someone
go, Hey, Pacman.
And I turned I was about 30 feet.
They watched me walk right by them, waited
until I was 20, 30 feet away, then said, Hey,
Pacman, I turn around, don't say anything,
just turn around.
And they say, you jue imperialist bastard,
change your ways.
And as I've said before, I'm not against the
principle of this technique.
If you're a public person and you're in public,
people are going to come up and give you their
opinion.
And most of the time people come up and they
say hello and they say they agree with my
opinions.
It just happened a few times this weekend.
And every once in a while someone might disagree.
This happened to be an ignorant moron who
was anti-Semitic, right?
Once they drop in, you Jew imperialist bastard.
But there's a different thing here.
It's not what I think about the technique.
What does Tucker himself think of the technique?
Well, Tucker came out in favor of this technique.
Remember when Tucker Carlson did an entire
segment on his show urging viewers to accost
mask wearing strangers and parents of children
who are being told to wear a mask?
Tucker said accost them on the street.
He encouraged it.
And so he must be OK with this technique,
right?
Well, according to The Daily Beast, reporter
Justin Baragwanath, a Fox News spokesperson,
said that the man in Montana was ambushing
Tucker Carlson in a store and that it was,
quote, totally inexcusable and that no public
figures should be accosted regardless of political
persuasion or beliefs due to the intolerance
of another point of view.
So wait a second, guys.
Tucker's view is parents who are not public
figures.
They're just parents.
If they are wearing masks or their kids are
wearing masks, even though they're not wanting
to be public people, they're not choosing
to be public people, they should be accosted
her.
Tucker Carlson.
But Tucker, as one of the highest rated hosts
on Fox News.
Who chooses to go out there and be a public
figure and say these things, he's off limits?
That's the point of view between Tucker and
Fox News.
It's deranged, guys.
It is absolutely and completely deranged.
These people are hypocrites when you know
the principles.
First, people not only you know, I've said
before, principles first is not always I mean,
OK, talk about principles, but the difficulty
is in applying the principles to the real
world.
And if you only talk about principles, you
lose reality.
That's one critique of principles first.
The other critique is a lot of the principles.
First, people abandon their principles as
soon as it's inconvenient to what they what
they actually want to experience in real life.
So absolutely pathetic and disgusting.
And this this is this has happened to me.
I've got to deal with it.
I could stop doing my show.
I could wear a disguise.
I could do whatever the hell I want.
But the idea that the arrest this man is just,
you know, it's peak cringe, Gigha cringe,
I think is what I would call it, in fact.